one woman is dead many others injured
after a horrific eight vehicle crash in
Mississauga police say a City boss
plowed into the vehicle stopped at a
traffic light on Derry Road and that
caused that Chain Reaction crash the
incident was caught on dash cam obtained
by global news Sean O'Shea joins us live
now from the scene with more Sean
and this happened right at 9 30 this
morning on this spot at rexwood and
Dairy Road East it involved just one
moving vehicle a Mississauga Transit bus
which was just towed from this area
about 15 minutes ago that whole
Collision was captured on a driver's
dash cam and a warning some viewers
might find the video disturbing the cars
were all stopped at this intersection
needy bambry was driving in one we were
standing on the red light and I was in
the middle lane behind the dump truck
then suddenly a Mississauga Transit bus
came crashing in plowing into a Nissan
Rogue crushing one car and then another
that it is eight vehicles that were
involved the video was captured on a
transport truck driver's dash cam I saw
it happening I'm like in front of me
the bus crashed into the cars couldn't
stop I don't know the brakes failed or
what happened to the driver she didn't
stop samrajeet Singh watched the crash
and jumped out to help the driver of
this car which was re-rented by the bus
the driver of the Nissan the gray Nissan
she was on the back seat of the car I
tried to talk to her
but she was not responding firefighters
tried to save the driver so did
paramedics of the female adult drivers
was taken to a local hospital in
life-threatening condition and a short
time later was pronounced deceased in
hospital other drivers and passengers
were also taken to hospital
no one else suffered life-threatening
injuries it's still under investigation
no charges have been laid just yet the
road was closed until late afternoon
when the vehicles were finally moved
away and as that happened the extent of
the damage was clear to see driver
samrajet Singh visibly upset at what
happened in front of him still can't
understand how something like this could
happen
Transit it was so fast I don't know how
can it fast be that fast
repeating that at this point the driver
has not been charged my way told us the
driver is in hospital being treated for
her injuries and that she's been placed
on leave penned the outcome of the
investigation and the transit authority
says it is fully cooperating with peel
Regional Police Alan
tragic incident there Sean thank you